c'est la plus ancienne école primaire et
secondaire de kaboul
les lycées malalai a vu défiler au cours
du siècle dernier des élèves qui
allaient pour certains fort millilitres
de la société afghane
dans cette classe de 6e année des filles
de 10 à 14 ans apprennent les rudiments
du français
la professeure fait quelques fautes mais
on peut difficilement billets en vouloir
c'est que hasina n'a que 16 ans et elle
n'est pas enseignante après la prise de
pouvoir des talibans le lycée a perdu
tous ses professeurs de français et
comme pour toutes les filles afghanes au
delà de la sixième année les talibans
décidé que hasina n'a plus le droit de
fréquenter les bancs d'école
mais
garda battant les millionnaires mal deux
alliés sur la manière
de
faire
le premier rang de la classe on remarque
tout de suite l'engouement de nadia et à
dia tour à tour et lève la main bien
haut pour prendre part aux exercices
elles n'ont pas l'intention de s'effacer
derrière les garçons
au soleil mac os chez
moi banda kani macarons chez le
charlatan que dalmat va pas il voit là
sa mort jamais connu le docteur rush
hour
l'une rêve de devenir juge l'autre peut
être médecin
une aspiration noble de servir son pays
mais l'an prochain elles seront trop
grande pour rester à l'école et
korean à l'exclusion forcé des salles de
classe et une double punition à
mi hauteur des eurocks sa bête un homme
vit can't go lorsque les secousses
because music and dance music is a long
de 80 go and co
ba vi can't go et n'osent même plus
jouer ses morceaux favoris sur le
clavier qu'elle a à la maison à
maladie cnam et
thomas
ligne à sa copine se sont elles aussi
réduite au silence mais faute de temps
avant
groupe 1
de
l'article 1
l'association promet qu en raison de
cette douleur dont elle parle elle a été
décuplé depuis l'arrivée au pouvoir des
talibans mais rihanna insiste ce n'est
pas de la peur nom de code avec un
antique
un ver note
romain
défaut thank you man
[Musique]
met
un masque
astorg
[Musique]
avait
redémarré
parole a su me répéter comme un mantra
auquel s'accrocher et qui rendent joly a
très fier cette enseignante féministe
cumulait deux postes à temps complet
pour subvenir aux besoins de sa famille
deux emplois qu'elle a perdu au pot aux
anneaux et assène que la veine centrale
canine monmarson noir au micro de ça ils
nous cassent comme
ses droits pour lesquels elle veut
continuer de se battre ils ont été
durement acquis par les femmes au cours
des vingt dernières années par le biais
d'une multitude de programmes d aide au
développement financés par la communauté
internationale c'était l'ultime
priorités du canada c'est comme les
emplois de giolias ses programmes
disparaissent l'arrivée des talibans
il ya une semaine déjà les talibans
continuer de dire que les filles plus
âgées pourrait retourner à l'école
bientôt il faut d'abord pouvoir assurer
leur sécurité et mettre en place une
ségrégation des sexes absolue ils sont
là pour coder c'est malalai la
directrice reste confiante que les
talibans respecteront leurs paroles
viotte mata silva ya ceux qui n'ont que
ça
à ma rose art aspect schéma sound
économique est tué à remédier à ses
causes selon mme chan à activation de
dammam et l embarras ziki ça crie ça
demande un effort
l'espoir c'est un mot qu'on prononce
très peu en afghanistan sauf pour dire
qu'il n'en reste presque plus
[Musique]